look at this data here from statista
this is not a political party this is
not a left this is not Fox this is not
CNN this is statista 72 percent of U.S
adults identify as LGBT just 40 years
ago was less than one percent wow okay
it's not 7.2 percent
and then if you go by 2014 where it was
okay yellow is Millennials gen Z's
didn't exist yet or green is genetic gen
X's then he got Boomers and he got uh
seniors right traditionalists if you go
to 2017 Millennials go up 20 20
Millennials go up 20 22 Millennials go
but look at gen Z right off the bat was
16 now 19.7 of gen Z's identify as LGBT
that's that's one in five Vinnie one in
French so now people say no one's
grooming what are you talking about what
do you mean they're just natural yeah
yeah they're choosing yeah on who they
want to be this is their choice no this
Statistics tells a story of what's going
on yeah and there's a reason why a lot
of parents are worried did you see a a
third Congressman just flipped from
democratic party oh I didn't see that
yeah it was third record three
representatives in the last 30 days that
flip from Republic from democratic to
Republican party two from Louisiana okay
well there's one in Carolina yeah one in
Carolina yeah and it just said we can't
we're going to the other side you're
going to see a lot more of these
happening because there are Democrats
that were Kennedy Democrats that are
sitting there just saying I don't know
man I just can't be going with this
anymore this kind of stuff is starting
to become very very weird right now yeah
well I just want to validate exactly
what you're saying with that I mean Bill
Maher did that about did you show that
the North Carolina person that flipped
so okay right there North Carolina yeah
and two more from Louisiana flipped as
well and go back to that statista if you
don't mind but here's actually something
that I think that we we should remember
I actually just saw this on Fox News I
sent you this story something that gen Z
does that no other generation does is
watch Tick Tock of all day if you don't
think that China who owns bite dance or
the CCP owns by tents is basically
promoting their algorithm to promote
this type of information to gen Z you'd
be foolish and you'd be naive here's
actually something I saw on Fox News
recently where this trans former trans
influencer basically saying hey I was
that guy I'm that dude like whatever I
drink the Kool-Aid or the Bud Light and
I'm full on blaming uh Tick Tock for the
rise of this gender ideology because you
know the algorithm on Tick Tock
basically it's like once they suck you
in boom you're going down that rabbit
hole so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]